(pensive music)
- [Narrator] President Joe Biden
and Republican House
Speaker, Kevin McCarthy,
have reached an agreement
to raise the debt ceiling.
- We still have a lot of work to do,
but I believe this is an
agreement in principle
that's worthy of the American people.
- [Narrator] The agreement
still needs to be approved
by Congress before June 5th
when the government could run
short of money to pay its debts
and fund government programs.
David Harrison covers the US economy
and the Federal Reserve for The Journal.
He explains what's in the deal
and whether Democrats or Republicans,
if anyone, came out ahead.
- The two big parts of this deal,
first of all, obviously, that
it raises the debt ceiling
for a couple years, basically pushes it
off to after the election.
The Republicans really got
an agreement to curb spending
for next year and to cap
it for the subsequent year.
- This deal is good news
I believe you'll see
(coughs) for the American people.
The agreement prevents
the worst possible crisis,
a default for the first time
in our nation's history.
- There are a lot of other smaller things.
There's new requirements that people
on food stamps either are employed
or are enrolled in some kind of program
and some provisions to streamline
or make it easier to get
energy projects approved.
- President Biden has delivered a result
that avoids a catastrophic default
that prevents us from
our economy crashing.
- Democrats got spending cuts
that were not nearly as deep
as the Republicans had
initially put forward.
Now comes the next phase,
which is Speaker McCarthy has
to sell this deal to his members,
to the House Republicans.
- We did a conference
call with our conference,
and over 95% were overwhelmingly excited
about what they see.
- A number of the more
conservative members
of the House GOP caucus have
come out in opposition to it,
calling it a disaster,
some calling it appalling,
basically saying that McCarthy gave
up too much to Democrats
to raise the debt ceiling.
Likewise, on the Democratic
side, some of the sort
of more progressive
Democrats are very concerned
about things like the work requirements
for aid programs, some
of the spending cuts.
- Terrible policy,
absolutely terrible policy.
Does not reduce spending,
actually, by some estimates,
creates a burden on
administrative spending
that is actually worse, you know,
for the overall cost
of a program like that.
- This bill's gonna have a
rough ride on Capitol Hill.
We've already heard from
some folks on the right
and on the left who oppose it.
And so now the question is
whether there'll be enough
in the middle to carry it through.
- We know, at any time
when you sit and negotiate
within two parties, that you gotta work
with both sides of the aisle,
so it's not 100% what everybody wants,
but when you look, the
country is gonna be stronger.
- [David] We have a June 5th deadline
to raise the debt ceiling
according to the Treasury Department.
If Congress does not raise
the the debt ceiling by then,
our government could quite literally run
out of money to pay its bills.
- I strongly urge both chambers
to pass that agreement.
Let's keep moving forward
on meeting our obligations
and building the strongest economy
in the history of the world.
(pensive music continues)